دعونا نسال الرجال
والسيدات سالنا الناس هنا في السعوديه هل
يمكن ان تتزوجوا من تكون اكبر منكم عمرا
دعونا نستمع الى الاجابات
[موسيقى]
اكيد واحده اقصر مني المهم ناقصني شيء ان
شاء الله
لازم يكون عمره اكبر عشان يداريها في
النضج
فانا الافضل ان اتزوج اصغر مني صراحه
العمر يعني ايش حيكون مجرد
والامور تمام ما فيها مشكله شوفوا الزواج
عادي
وسنه من سنن الحياه وما فيها مشكله شكرا
طالما ان هناك
يعني اتفاق في التفكير العلمي الثقافي
على حد ما او بنسبه جدا عاليه
اكبر مني بسنه سنتين ثلاثه
فاذا يعني توفر بنا توافق ويكون في مجال
يعني
متواصل ومباشر بين الطرفين اكيد بتربطنا
علاقه قويه واستمراريه واتفاقيه انه نكون
على وجه الاستعداد لمرحله الزواج
[موسيقى]